I'm a normal human being there's
frustrations there's disappointments but
my inability to sit with something that
isn't going well professionally or
personally is very low I very quickly go
to a higher plane intentionally or just
naturally naturally and then it became
intentional we lose a big account I sit
on it I might be upset I may think about
what did we do to [__] it up within an
hour I go into okay or we could have
kept this account and like my siblings
could have gotten hurt or my child or my
mom you know what I mean I go real [__]
somewhere pretty quickly back to a good
place I just spend so much energy on
what I'm grateful for versus what I'm
dwelling
about